on our hypothetical journey we've
already tested out living on a flat
earth a cubical earth even a Hollow
Earth so what do you say we try to
survive on an earth with a giant hole in
the middle would a planet like this even
have a chance of being habitable would
it still have the moon
how would gravity work and what would
the view be like on an earth like this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth was shaped like a
doughnut hey planet airily speaking size
matters and so does shape this is what
mathematicians would call a toroidal
world or a torus planet to me it's an
earth shaped like a sweet fried ring
shaped pastry whatever you call this
earth theoretically it's not impossible
planets don't naturally form in the
shape of a doughnut but the laws of
physics do allow for such worlds to
exist it just wouldn't be earth as you
know it
okay I'm just messing with you here it
wouldn't kill anyone to evolve on a
doughnut-shaped
earth unless it had a shape more like a
hula hoop having a center that's so much
larger than the physically solid portion
of Earth would result in some very
unstable conditions
see what I mean disastrous so let's
focus on a planet that looks like a
traditional donut and closely mimics our
own earth this donut shaped earth would
have a similar position relative to the
Sun and the same actual tilt it would
even have a similar escape velocity 11.4
km/s for most of the planet at the
donuts equator the escape velocity would
go down to just six and a half
kilometers per second so if you were
going to send rockets into space that
would be the best place to break free of
the gravitational clutches of a donut
shaped earth speaking of gravity
depending where you were on a torus
earth you'd weigh up to three times less
than you usually do if our round earth
has a surface gravity of 1g the surface
gravity of a donut earth along the poles
would be 0.65 g and at the equator the
gravity would go down to just 0.3 g it
would be like walking on the surface of
mars
even though the doughnut shaped Earth's
gravity would be lower than what you're
used to it would still be constantly
trying to collapse the planet in on
itself
to fight the urge to become a sphere
shaped earth a donut earth would have to
spin much faster than our round earth
does that way centrifugal forces would
kick in and keep the donut hole intact
but because of this quick rotation a day
on earth would only last two hours and
50 minutes or if you prefer to stick to
a traditional 24 hour day you'd be
dealing with at least eight sunrises and
sunsets every day you'd have to adapt to
working day and night and sleeping
through hours of daylight but it would
be much worse than that for the animals
that are synced to the patterns of the
moon and the Sun to breed migrate and
hunt oh and by the way what would happen
to the moon well the good news is we'd
still have it most likely it would be
pulled towards the middle of the hole
and bob up and down in the middle of the
planet or it could be affected by the
gravity of the donuts outer edges and
create a figure-eight orbit around the
earth the bad news is either if these
orbits would affect the tides on earth
and wreak a little havoc oceans could
have such unstable water levels that
having coastal cities might not be a
thing
the overall climate on a doughnut earth
would be similar to what we currently
have on our round earth it would be
colder in the polar regions and warmer
at the equator but the weather would be
a little more extreme and could even
make some parts of the planet
inhospitable due to storms and
hurricanes it's hard to predict where
the countries would be located on a
tourist planet but as far as topography
goes most likely the doughnut hole would
be lined with mountains and they could
be substantially larger than anything we
have on earth right now
if you wanted to live on the inner edge
of a doughnut shaped earth you'd be
enjoying this view unlike in some
what-if scenarios life wouldn't come to
an end in this one humans of a doughnut
earth might never cross the ocean
they'd evolved separately on different
continents but at least there would be
no mass extinction and no areas of the
planet would become too extreme for us
to survive donut earthers might or might
not have the tools and tech they might
not even stumble onto the concept of a
donut
in the first place or they could be
making videos like what if the earth was
shaped like a ball and maybe because of
this doughnut shape some disasters in
Earth's history would never have
happened but that's a story for another
[Music]
you
[Music]